it's a pill a Capcom exclusive have made
a huge splash with this album now we
were just kind of talking I don't can I
share them with Montana story I talked
about outside or you want to keep that
off the record well I heard that uh that
la Reid flew to Montana to see you what
was that last week yeah maybe like a
week and a half a week and a half ago
after the album went number two yeah
right yeah so LA Reid flies to Missoula
Montana yeah
Missoula Montana it just sounds exactly
what it sounds like
you know what I've said yes yes but to
try to try to sign you is this correct I
mean yeah I don't know how you know
in-depth and for one I didn't tell he
didn't tell me I had heard this from
someone else in the image yeah I didn't
I didn't say that yeah but um yeah you
know him and his team came out and we
you know haven't had a conversation and
since then we've you know been in
contact with their team and I think they
came out to the Santa Anas show and you
know my managers been in contact with
them many other labels have been in
contact for the last couple weeks you
know the end of every show we have
somebody from some label that
but you know for me right now and you
know decisions need to be made I'm
really happy that we did it
independently I think that we're gonna
continue to try to go that route if
there's something that makes sense which
I've always said I've never said like
I'm doing this independence my life
optimation yeah it's gotta make sense
yeah I think that um you know we'll see
what happens but at this point it
completely remains independent and we're
having conversations la Reid was super
cool his team was super cool it was
really dope it icon and a legend like
Ellaria lie to Montana Montana had he
ever been to Montana no of course not
he flew to Montana and that was a super
humbling so yeah so - what have him
watch the show and be juiced out the
show and excited that was just freshen
itself hey who are you come here being
from the Northwest you know I lived in
Idaho for a little bit and it is that's
not necessarily like the same as he had
on Portland but you know it's just it's
a different a different vibe in the
northwest man and I think anywhere else
who were some of your like big
influences coming from Seattle like that
rappers from Sierra but just that part
of the country you don't hear a lot from
a lot of people who do music from that
part of the country so yeah who are your
influences that we're from Seattle no no
no just in general I mean I grew up with
west coast gangsta rap like snooping
DPG and you know just typical West Coast
rap as a kid and when I got older I
started to get into more underground
West Coast rap and then you had the East
Coast like I was really into wu-tang
like I was you know a sixth grader who
was you know like I used to tag all my
little binders with the wu-tang W yeah
exactly perfect drawing that [__] the
right yeah I think I still got some
those binders but you know mile-deep
Fugees wu-tang you know biggie
you know things of that nature a little
bit later got into Thai live and most
right kind of the raucous era of course
um of hip-hop and you know was real
backpacker and hieroglyphics and living
legends and you know freestyle
fellowship a lot of it was West Coast
like style j5 used to be mushroom yeah
j5 was dope like you know just a ton of
a ton of you know more backpacker
independent type rappers when I was in
high school speaking to independent
people whenever I try to put people up
on your music if they're you know fans
of underground hip-hop a lot of times
people say he kind of sounds like slug
from atmosphere yeah do you hear that a
lot you know I heard it I mean yeah I
mean I I get a couple tweets a day all
right
someone was just like he sounds like
atmospheres on Twitter like 30 minutes
ago oh wow you know what like I get it
less and less I think that um you know I
understand that immediately people draw
comparisons especially not for known if
you're a white rap and that's I'm saying
especially if you're a white guy compare
you to another be somebody but you know
honestly like nowadays I don't get it
any more than I get like you know Mac
Miller or Asher Roth right are yellow
wolf like people I sound nothing like
right right right you know I think that
one thing that's dope is that you know
speaking of atmosphere is what he's been
able to do with with rhyme stairs
yeah really put on from you know
independent music straight up and they
really have a Empire them yeah they do
they have the Empire and I've you know
watched it over the years so you know
that's been you know probably the
biggest influence in terms of you know
my musical career is not actually the
music although it's dope but it's more
just what they've done it's like there
are okay yeah absolutely it's it's
something to definitely be staying like
that I think tech and atmosphere there's
absolutely are the two kind of like
models too if you want to do it
independently yeah in there yeah coming
in text is just like I mean they travel
with like you know a whole [__] they
got their own oh yeah yes everything
their merch game is just like you can't
you can't compare it cannot touch
they're on a whole nother level and what
and like I've seen pictures I've been
we've we've done a couple shows are
gonna like couple festive bright college
shows
me in tech but I've seen like when they
tour they had like you know a massive
wall of just like 40 different t-shirt
designers like it's like a store no it
is
they got socks I got ties yeah they got
whatever you need tonight a strange logo
on exactly so he's crazy
hey the thrift shop record I really I
came up man
me and my mommy's always go to the
thrift store I started to get all my
[__] yeah yeah and it's just the videos
is hilarious it's just a great feel good
record how much of your wardrobe do you
honestly get from the thrift shop at
this point in time you probably got so
much free clothes that you could get
from like late like I don't have a brain
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of that right now which is funny like
you know let's come after the throw out
video now I have a hell of label clothes
but um for me it's I have I have just
too many clothes in general like I have
I would say probably 40% of my stuff is
from thirst shops
you know I'm not buying Jean's at their
shops I'm not buying socks I'm not
behind drawers you gotta have like some
good shirts you gotta have some good
he's like I like a coats I like I like
nice stuff to like worse you know I was
in LA yesterday and bought a diamond
gold ring at a pawn shop like I'm just a
random dude I went to the Arizona mall
today and picked this up I sent a
Fernandes fake that's what I'm saying so
for me it's just about being random and
doing things that people wouldn't expect
and being myself I'm just a weird Gemini
like I like to random stuff so one day I
want to be suited up and you know hit
Barney's and another day I want to go
and you know Spence when he doesn't come
out with the outfit so yeah hey when you
I know everyone makes music I you know I
would like to think when people make
hip-hop music they first do it for the
love you know some people do it for
money sure but when you are making music
I mean now that you are on a larger
stage as far as the attention you're
getting yeah
you've touched on so many issues in your
music I mean when you make music you
consciously like because I think you're
the kind of dude what makes make songs
that someone you might mess around a
changed someone's life when they hear
some of your records you know what I'm
saying is that so I'm you doing purpose
or you do you have a conscious when it
comes to like what kids get out of your
music you know I'm aware of it I think
that you can't go into writing a song
trying to do that right you can't go
almost like you can't go into a song
trying to make a hit yeah exactly has to
be organic it has to be organic it's the
exact same thing and it's usually when
I'm going through something that like
that's what comes out and she's honestly
it's just honestly man and the minute
that I try to force that or that I'm
like oh we have too many climbing
records on the album like I need to be
serious like I'm gonna spend a month
trying to make serious and it's gonna be
whack but when real life happens and
you're aware and you're and you're opens
or whatever is coming through you and
you document that that's when those
songs happen and they usually write
themselves like you know the songs that
you know I would put into that category
of potentially changing kids lives or
people's lives our songs that I was just
I just happen to be there and just
caught some sort of spirit and let that
and I hope that Interscope tries to sign
you so you could play Jimmy Iovine the
Jimmy Iovine record I know what yeah I
think that they definitely were aware of
that like the first day that that record
came out that's awesome
yeah that's awesome a man will Congrats
all the haters I remember when the Excel
double XL freshmen came out sure
everyone was like who the [__] is
Macklemore and why is he on the cover
but boom guys not the number two I'm in
the country man it's it's a it's a good
luck man thanks for making the music you
make my dude I appreciate you
I appreciate you and what you're doing
congratulations on them no doubt for
sure cause anything out bro sorry